here
Hydro Dozier chocolate time we we might
be sipping on gin or Hennessy with that
new oh my God The Chronic
hi I'm Chris Pratt it's wow I'm Chris
Pratt she's Chris Pratt oh wow this is
for unilad
and it's do you even know me and by the
way she's Zoe Saldana and he's Chris
Pratt that's right
classic classic prank
my favorite body part
my left big toe
my hands or my eyes
it's it's an attractive big toe
God they're all amazing I mean it says
toss up I'm paying him to say that oh
it's working
I'm gonna go with hands I'm gonna say
hands correct yeah it's him because
she's not gonna say like what's my
favorite part of my eyes because her
eyes are so beautiful but no no one
who's as humble as is always going to
talk about how great her eyes are I
should be in a freaking detection
you CSI celebrity but that's what 10
years gets you man we do we we pay
attention you know what I'm saying which
nickname did my friends give me in high
school a pratatouille
be monkey boy or C goat Lord
Ratatouille
monkey boy
I was I had giant ears and giant teeth
and then my head grew into it like in my
mid-20s yeah yeah so my dad called me
monkey boy and it just stuck oh my God
if only they knew you were just a really
good listener yeah right thank you but
practically needs to take off right
Ratatouille
hello that should be it should be
Ratatouille by the way yeah what was my
party trick a I can guess the number
someone is thinking of B I can move my
eyeballs in different directions and see
I can burp the alphabet
uh backwards b
I can move my eyeballs in different
directions Chris could you do it I can
okay okay
oh wow
I showed you that party drink I remember
we've done that oh my gosh okay your
turn
close your eyes what color are my eyes
green oh
really good A little Hazel sometimes
sometimes I didn't even know that how
did you know that that's incredible
obsessed
that's true because Brad's with my
projects do we
what was I suspended from school for
making stink bombs stole a hamster from
the biology lab starting a food fight
and getting rice in my Teacher's hair
uh see
close I was making stink bombs is that
true isn't that a girl oh that's a way
better answer I'm glad that's your
answer what's the story behind that well
I was dating this boy and he uh was
really curious about stink bombs and I
remember that he and I like researched
it and we thought okay so if you grab
like a jar and you put in a whole bunch
of things on like a boiled egg and you
bury it for like a week
um you can create a sink bomb
so and then all you do is extract like
two or three little dots just one little
dot or a drop I'm sorry one little drop
or two drops on a table or something is
is K it's can stink up a whole room so
when everybody was in recess we went
upstairs and we um we We spelled the jar
and like literally like school was over
so I got suspended yeah we both got
suspended wow wow I mean I'm gonna take
that back yeah the right little trick
that's serious courtship okay oh Isaac
which of these albums do I know uh know
by heart Dr Dre Chronic 2001 doggy style
Snoop Dogg American Idiot Green Day I'm
I you know what I think it's between Dr
Dre and Snoop Dogg yeah
Chronic 2000
years
when we might be sipping on gin or
Hennessy with that dude
what is my go-to karaoke song A about
damn time by lizzo B To Be With You by
Mr Big or C No Scrubs by TLC oh you know
what listen
I think I'm gonna go with
I don't know the answer to this I'm
gonna have to kind of go process of
elimination I don't think your go-to
karaoke song would be a lizzo song
because I think you've been singing
karaoke longer than Liz has been really
uh hitting the career so I'm going to
rule that out I think
I don't want no scrubs might be I could
see you and your sister out singing that
when you were young that's when that
song was out you were all hot and like
that was a song that you and you girls
were saying I'm gonna go with I don't
want no scrubs
it was Mr big oh no way you I'm an 80s
kid oh I should have known that yeah
you're Richard Marx and all that stuff
Mr Biggs No Scrubs I I never used to
touch like Scrubs
I was so like afraid of rapping because
English was not my first time
dang it
I guess I'm nothing but a scrub now
hold on little girl you're such a great
song Oh that song
I get emotional but I'm also like at
that time but um I I remember my sister
broke up with like a boyfriend and she
had like a little broken heart and I
sang her that song a karaoke we must
have been like
17 18 19 because we're all a year apart
and then that became like my staple song
so every time we used to be out they
always would have a little too much of
drinks like saying Mr bad so that became
like my thought oh my God I cannot wait
to go go do some karaoke and hear that
soon yes Brass Monkey that's good what's
yours oh gosh I don't really know I
usually go for comedy so you know try to
be funny so I'll do like uh uh Scorpions
hurricane or something like that German
accent or I'll do like uh oh I used to
do uh that do you remember from what was
it Cable Guy Jim Carrey does a rendition
of uh Somebody to Love by Jefferson
Airplane
so I would sing that because I wanted to
do everything Jim Carrey did which of
these awards did I win in 2019 the
American Dental Association celebrity
smile of the Year well
[Laughter]
the Kids Choice Awards favorite butt
kicker
[Laughter]
you're right you're also nominated that
year I was yeah
and I won yeah
better
what is my biggest fear
a the fear of holes I'm not gonna say
the word because I probably don't know
it B the fear of drowning and C the fear
of long words
[Laughter]
but it's it's tough because you because
you were like I don't want to say the
long word I know and then the third one
was long words but I think it's fear of
drowning it's fair
enough tryptophobia
thalassophobia oh wow
[Laughter]
hippopotamonstrassis
quippedaliophobic phobia phobia
hippopotomonstross equippedaliophobia do
you understand this is insane that's
amazing where was I discovered
a someone mistook me for a model in
Abercrombie and Fitch
probably
B I went
to the toilet during a theater show
walked through the wrong door and ended
up on stage in an ensemble or see a
bubble gum shrimp restaurant
and um and bubble gum oh really yes
you're very handsome Gohan which of
these did I want to be as a child a a
dentist be a chicken farmer or c a
ballet dancer well a ballet dancer
you were a ballet dancer
with secret uh Ambitions to be a chicken
farmer but uh ballet dancer yes yeah
absolutely
that's why she's such a an extraordinary
uh fighter in in the films I mean the
choreography of the fights and like
where she can pose on a red carpet the
liveness the beauty the statuesque
presence it all comes from continue from
house comes from dancing he's a keeper
in which of these events did I compete
at a state level
the great Midwest Rib Fest World
Championship
Washington State Wrestling Championships
the South Hawaii chess tournament oh
we're in between the Hawaii chess
tournament and wrestling
wrestling yeah
yeah but you want to do the red one
right oh I'd Crush that yeah yeah it
exists that's a really good that's a
really good uh multiple choice that's
really tricky because all three of those
things I could see myself entering a
contest eating ribs for sure playing
chess maybe you know I can enter but I
probably wouldn't win
oh okay in which TV show did I make my
on-screen debut uh Law and Order Sex in
the City ER
oh my gosh well this is tense
probably I'm listen I'm I'm gonna think
that it was most of the guest stars in
sex in the city were men which is
already a big ensemble cast of females
so I'm gonna rule that out
uh but you are from New York and I know
there's a lot of Law and Order and I
could see you playing like a super
beautiful young victim of something so
I'm gonna go with law order
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you know you're going places
when you when you book your first
episode yeah episodic you're like you're
like and it wouldn't and I would have
gotten away with it too if it weren't
for you yeah yeah yes I killed him yes I
killed him it was more like this like
you know he did it so just say it admit
it
like great can we do it again really you
wanted but that yeah again can you go a
little more Queens on this one okay and
action you know he did it so just admit
it great oh that was very very good now
I want to just go one last time this
time will really amp up the Queens but
do it in a way that you actually hate
Rosie Perez would you want me to say it
in Spanish yes
and I booked it and that's it that's our
girl
can you tell my husband this because
he's like this is so weird that we have
to be in bedroom number he waits until
he thinks I'm asleep and then he throws
bunny out of bed no yeah and I get so
mad I'm like take everybody out of bed